eager to learn more about the comics
that inspired wandavision
then you're in luck here are the comics
to read if you want to know more about
vision wanda and her history as the
scarlet witch
the 1980s saw two volumes of the vision
in the scarlet witch series
both of which are worth any one division
fan's time the first volume which
premiered in 1982
sees our newlywed heroes making a
wholehearted attempt to live like normal
people or
at least as normal as the synthezoid and
a witch can ever be
their attempt to retire to suburban new
jersey is of course
immediately disrupted by magic mayhem
and magneto
this four issue series tackles a lot
despite its brevity
particularly spotlighting wanda's
complex parentage
that family drama combines wonderfully
with old-fashioned superheroics
and is perfectly topped off by wanda and
vision's irresistibly off-beat
relationship
the second volume of vision in the
scarlet witch hit newsstands in 1985
the intervening years put wanda and
vision through the ringer and so
more in love than ever they decide to go
back to new jersey for a quiet life
together
as ever things get complicated but their
bond is at its most compelling in the 12
issues that make up this run
wanda's pregnancy provides the series
backbone she conceives her sons through
magic in the third issue and gives birth
in the 12th
twins what a twist
in between fans are treated to the site
of magneto attending a suburban
thanksgiving
vision doing his best to look casual in
blue jeans and scarlet witch partying in
new orleans clad in a maternity costume
it is in short adorable and highly
recommended for
anyone who loves wandavision's kooky
portrayal of domestic bliss
once upon a time a witch and a robot had
two beautiful baby boys
then along came a little series called
avengers west coast
and it's 1989 darker than scarlet arc
which takes a sledgehammer to wanda and
vision's happiness
this storyline is essentially the
beginning of
every scarlet witch-centric comics event
storyline
and series of the last three decades
it's no stretch to say that what
transpires in these pages is the reason
wandavision exists darker than scarlet
reveals tommy and billy
wanda and vision's beloved twin sons to
be magical constructs
as agatha harkness wanda's erstwhile
mentor in witchcraft
explains wanda's desire for stable
domesticity was so great
she unconsciously used two free-floating
fragments of soul to conceive
tommy and billy horrifically the soul
shards she used
belong to mephisto a top-tier demon and
persistent marvel baddie
wanda is naturally traumatized though
agatha
magically walls off the part of wanda's
consciousness which houses all memories
of the boys
it doesn't stick soon after wanda
plunges into outright
villainy and a baddie named immortus is
brought into the mix
the major takeaway here is twofold first
wanda
is a toweringly powerful witch of
bordering on
divine proportions second her
subconscious desire for normalcy is so
strong
it can assert itself through her powers
without her consciously knowing about it
sound like a certain mcu show you know
of i don't know
i don't know and i don't know 1998's
avengers number 10
examines wanda's origins with a fresh
eye granted
many of the details covered in this
issue have since been retconned
wanda's powers are here described as
being rooted in chaos magic
she is identified as a mutant and
magneto is treated as her biological
father
currently none of that is true and a
whole lot of storylines have come and
gone which painter has significantly
less in control of her powers
but still this issue stands firm as a
solid look at who wanda
is and what has shaped her while a
raucous parade celebrating the avengers
goes on elsewhere
wanda travels to visit agatha harkness
the rye old witch who tutored her in
magic
wanda's powers are troubling her
especially her newfound ability to bring
wonderment back from the dead
agatha agrees that this is concerning
but notably
she also believes that wanda can learn
to control her prodigious powers
as so many subsequent storylines have
painted wanda is being driven to
destructive madness by her abilities
it's a wonderful change of pace to see
her treated as unquestionably
up to the task of harnessing them tragic
reality
warping isn't going to stop being part
of her story any time soon
but it's also not the sole element of
her story
wanda is at her best when she is treated
as being capable of growing beyond her
worst days
something this issue and the mcu knows
well
2004's avengers disassembled event
begins with the arrival of jack of
hearts at the avengers door
this is strange as he just died it gets
a whole lot stranger when his undead
corpse
explodes taking out ant-man things go
from bad to worse tony stark becomes
inexplicably drunk while delivering a
speech at the un
vision crashes a quinjet into avengers
mansion and hawkeye is killed
in a cree attack the avengers go into
crisis mode looking for any and all
answers as to what
exactly is tearing their team apart on
so many fronts
finally doctor strange appears wanda he
reveals
is to blame for these tragedies the loss
of her twin sons who were in fact
magical constructs wanda willed into
being has been lurking within her like a
ticking time bomb
finally set off by an innocuous comment
from the wasp
the chaos of the past few days is all
down to her
lashing out in rage and madness on a
scale only someone with reality warping
powers could pull off this storyline
casts wanda and her powers in a
terrifying light and fundamentally
altered her place in the marvel universe
it also led to house of m a storyline
that might be the most climactic
in wanda's entire history though many of
avengers disassembled's details have
been retconned over the years its
shocking events
haven't been forgotten and neither has
the way it framed rwanda as a rogue
warhead capable of untold destruction
2005's house of m storyline hinges upon
the nigh god-like nature of wanda's
powers and specifically
what might be her most dramatic use of
them
this tale unfolds in the aftermath of
the avengers disassembled event
which sees wanda fly into a murderous
rage upon being reminded of her lost
twin sons
after she is taken down by doctor
strange the marvel universe's top tier
superheroes debate
what to do with her but before they can
take action wanda remakes the world
entirely our heroes wake up in a reality
ruled by mutants with magneto and his
house of m
at the very top of the heap eventually
our heroes realize the truth
and a battle ensues at its apex scarlet
witch appears
she rages against magneto for dooming
her and her brother pietro to
dysfunction for the sake of his mutant
ideals
tearfully clutching her brother's
battered body she utters an immortal
line
no more mutants when our heroes return
to their reality
they find that the vast majority of the
world's mutants have become
everyday humans like avengers
disassembled this storyline treats wanda
as a terrifyingly
potent force but there's a notably
tragic heir to these proceedings
her actions are shocking but it's hard
not to sympathize with her as she lashes
out at magneto for his exploitation and
cruelty
wanda has tried once more to fix her own
broken heart and by extension what she
perceives to be a broken world
the consequences are unforgettable
billy and tommy wanda and vision's twin
sons have a long
strange history in the marvel universe
sometimes they're real
sometimes they're illusions sometimes
they're fragments of uber demon
mephisto's soul
the 2000's however saw them come into
their own as billy kaplan and tommy
shepard aka
wiccan and speed stalwart members of the
young avengers
they're not exactly the sons wanda gave
birth to basically their reincarnations
of those kids born to other families
the exact nature of their connection is
a little fuzzy but
the fact that it's meaningful is clear
billy
has wanda-ish reality warping magic that
borders on
godhood while tommy has pietro's white
hair and super speed
one division could very well be setting
up tommy and billy for their mcu
entrance and there's no
better way to get acquainted with them
than checking out their time as members
of the young avengers
2005's young avengers series is a great
introduction to both characters
while 2010's avengers the children's
crusade sees them confront their nature
as reincarnated pseudo-children head on
2013's young avenger run takes things in
a slightly different
direction a young loki is in the mix
intradimensional shenanigans take place
and billy saves the world by kissing his
boyfriend hulkling
but it's one well worth exploring is
everything having to do with tommy and
billy a little confusing
yes is it entertaining also yes so it
goes in comics especially when the
scarlet witch is involved
2015's vision series hit the comics
landscape like an
asteroid the first issue introduces
vision's new home in the dc
suburbs which he is filled with his
similarly new wife
daughter and son they're all synthezoids
their hair is green their skin is red
and they boast all the fabulous
abilities the man of the house possesses
yet they are living as a normal american
family behold into homework dishes and
deadlines
the kids viv and vin deal with school
virginia their mother attends
parent-teacher conferences
and vision heads off to work in the
morning though of course that work often
involves fighting skyscraper tall
monsters
over the course of 12 tightly written
issues vision
unravels white vision has thrown himself
into pursuing a normalcy
so at odds with his own nature and the
ways in which it was a doomed project
from the start this isn't a spoiler the
first issue's narration introduces a
neighbor couple then
immediately describes the deaths
awaiting them at the hands of vision's
family
in declaring its intentions so early
vision
allows itself to explore the
heart-wrenching complexity of vision's
journey with a unique
level of introspection his relationship
with wanda might
not be spotlighted here but the shadow
it casts over the entire affair
is long and explored in especially
affecting detail in the series seventh
issue
in exploring the impossibility of
vision's quest to be normal
vision takes the character to dizzying
new heights of humanity
monica rambo has gone by many names over
the years
and we're not talking about her time as
geraldine the energy warping powerhouse
has been called spectrum
photon pulsar and captain marvel through
it all
she has been defined by her tenacity
courage and
above all her top shelf leadership
skills
the 1980s were good to monica 1983 saw
her join the avengers while 1989 brought
captain marvel
monica's very first solo series to the
stands
but as far as introductions to the
character 1987's avengers number 279
is where it's at the wasp has stepped
down as chairwoman of the avengers and
to monica's surprise
captain america nominates her to lead
the team next
though she's flattered she's unsure if
she's ready to accept such a huge
responsibility
as she ruminates over her decision she
visits her parents
recalls the day she got her powers helps
cap save kids
trapped in a cave and visits colleagues
in the hospital basically
it covers everything that makes her who
she is the love instilled in her by her
family her disinterest in suffering
fools
and her deep sense of compassion in the
end
she accepts the position and goes on to
lead the avengers with skill
empathy and perseverance might we see
her do the same in the mcu
only time will tell but it sure seems
like one division is setting her up for
big things marvel sure does love their
shadowy governmental organizations don't
they
sword introduced to the mcu v01 division
is only one of many
but it's definitely one of the coolest
sword made its debut in 2004's
astonishing x-men number three
via abigail brand the organization's
leader appearing in the shadows behind
nick fury sword's acronym stands for
slightly different words than it does in
the mcu
here they're the sentient world
observation and response department
while on one division they're the
sentient weapon
observation and response division
basically sort is like an intelligence
agency that deals with extraterrestrial
threats
like shield they keep their own council
and like fury brand is a gruff
no-nonsense leader who cares a whole lot
more about getting the job done then
making sure she doesn't hurt anyone's
feelings
though this run doesn't feature wanda or
vision it's a great look at the sort of
space-centric storytelling that seems
likely to define the mcu's future
and serves as a solid introduction to
the governmental apparatus that acts as
the earth's
front line of defense plus it's an
enormous amount of fun and
totally accessible to even the most
uninitiated readers
now who's ready to put money on whether
a marvel's agents of sword series will
be coming to disney plus anytime soon
2015 scarlet witch had a lot to tackle
few marvel characters have a more
convoluted backstory than wanda to say
nothing of the turmoil her powers have
caused writer james robinson who worked
with a plethora of artists on this
visually inventive series
takes an intriguing and unique approach
to this state of affairs
he confronts wanda with a magical
landscape as broken as she herself
feels in so doing scarlet witch faces
the character's dysfunction head-on
championing her as someone of courage
and cleverness
even as it reckons with her darkest
hours wanda begins in new york city
where she realizes witchcraft itself has
become sick
she proceeds to travel across the world
in her efforts to heal her craft
agatha harkness's sarcastic ghost at her
side
scarlet witch's greatest triumph is that
it takes wanda seriously
she isn't treated as a dangerous mad
woman a fragile way for a miserable
penitent
but as a woman attempting to forge a
future for herself in a strange and
often contradictory universe elements of
her backstory which have historically
been treated as exotic window dressing
get real meaningful focus here
especially her romani roots
which she explores in serbia this series
takes it as a given that wanda is a
multi-faceted creature
and as a result reframes her entire
history as one of heroic struggle
rather than tragic instability in short
it treats her like an
honest-to-goodness superhero and somehow
it makes it look
easy check out one of our newest videos
right here plus even more looper videos
about your favorite comic book heroes
and villains are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one